y
[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 el
secretario de estado de eeuu antonio
wing quien llegó a israel una visita con
la que busca reforzar el alto el fuego
entre este país el grupo islamista hamás
en la franja de gaza para que éste sea
duradero blinken encuentra un escenario
polarizado y detención con un gobierno
de israel defensivo y una palestina
dividida
irán anunció la lista de los siete
candidatos que disputarán las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 18 de junio
la decisión del consejo de guardianes
deja por fuera a varios aspirantes entre
ellos al ex presidente mahmud
ahmadineyad quien aspiraba a un nuevo
mandato mientras que el para james raíz
y clérigo que lidera la judicatura del
país se perfila como el gran favorito en
las encuestas
y el gobierno de colombia rechazó de
manera momentánea la visita de la
comisión interamericana de los derechos
humanos y de la organización de estados
américanos los organismos buscaban
investigar las denuncias de violaciones
a los derechos humanos en represión y
abuso policial en el marco de las
protestas ciudadanas de otra parte el
ministro de defensa del país se enfrentó
el primer debate de una moción de
censura por su liderazgo de las fuerzas
armadas
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález vamos a comenzar en medio
oriente el secretario de estado de eeuu
anthony blinken inició una gira por esta
región con el esfuerzo de tratar de
reducir las tensiones y fortalecer el
alto el fuego entre israel y las
milicias de hamás en la franja de gaza-
en la ciudad de jerusalén blinken se
reunió con el primer ministro israelí
benjamín netanyahu a quien instó a
construir sobre la tregua alcanzada para
evitar el retorno de la violencia 11
días de conflicto armado dejaron más de
250 muertos de ambas partes la gran
mayoría de ellos palestinos blinken se
comprometió a reunir apoyo internacional
para ayudar a la reconstrucción de la
franja de gaza- por su parte el primer
ministro israelí benyamín netanyahu
advirtió que la respuesta de su país
será muy poderosa y jamás viola la
tregua
tres españas el presidente de byd en me
pidió que viniera hoy aquí en realidad
por cuatro razones primero para
demostrar el compromiso de eeuu con la
seguridad de israel para comenzar a
trabajar hacia una mayor estabilidad y
reducir las tensiones en cisjordania y
jerusalén para apoyar la asistencia
humanitaria urgente y asistencia para la
reconstrucción de gaza en beneficio del
pueblo palestino
y para continuar reconstruyendo nuestra
relación con el pueblo palestino y la
autoridad palestina es néstor y serán
siete los candidatos que participarán en
las elecciones presidenciales de irán
previstas para el 18 de junio estos
siete candidatos fueron autorizados a
comenzar sus respectivas campañas tras
recibir el aval del estricto grupo que
lidera la judicatura de la república
islámica así las cosas la decisión
tomada por el consejo de guardianes
convierte en favorito a ibrahim raeissi
quien se presentó como candidato en el
2017 y perdió ante el actual presidente
hassan rohan y de otra parte sorprendió
que este consejo no aceptara la
candidatura del ex
y mahmud ahmadineyad ni la del ex
presidente del parlamento alí lariyaní
quienes quedaron ya por fuera de esta
contienda electoral desde teherán la
capital iraní en catalina gómez ángel
nos da más detalles del panorama
electoral en la república islámica
estas elecciones estaban llamadas a ser
dominadas por el sector conservador y
radical esto se debe a que el consejo de
guardianes de guardianes una junta de
dos expertos en ley
han venido eliminando en los últimos
años a los candidatos reformistas y
moderados un sector al que pertenece el
presidente
hassan rohan y aún así los iraníes se
llevaron una gran sorpresa hoy al saber
que algunos candidatos pertenecientes al
sector moderados muy de las entrañas del
régimen como el ex portavoz del
parlamento alí lariyaní habían quedado
eliminados o también el vicepresidente
actual del campo reformista el señor
jahangir y es así como esta lista de
siete personas que fue publicada hoy
la mayoría son conservadores radicales
solamente a un candidato del reformismo
y otro del sector moderado pero sin
ninguna oportunidad para ganar y deja
así que la lista o un solo ganador según
lo dicen las redes sociales iraníes esta
mañana se trata del jefe de la justicia
ibrahim raeissi que también fue
derrotado
hace 4 años por el presidente de hassan
roja ni nadie piensa que vaya a tener un
contendor y la gran pregunta hoy es qué
tanta participación habrá las próximas
elecciones en otros temas el gobierno de
colombia rechazó de momento la visita de
la comisión interamericana de los
derechos humanos y de la organización de
estados américanos que pretendían llegar
a este país para investigar las
diferentes denuncias hechas por
organizaciones y ciudadanos de
violaciones a los derechos humanos
represión y abuso policial de otra parte
en el pleno del congreso de colombia
tuvo lugar un intenso debate sobre la
moción de censura al ministro de defensa
diego molano quien lleva sólo cuatro
meses en el cargo el ministro respondió
sobre la actuación de la fuerza pública
en medio de las protestas que por
espacio de casi un mes han sacudido a
colombia molano llega a este debate con
poco apoyo y se enfrenta a una oposición
cargada de pruebas por más de 462 vídeos
imágenes y audios de personas que
participaron en las manifestaciones en
más de 35 ciudades colombianas
que evidenciaron el abuso policial el
debate contó además con la intervención
de varias víctimas que han dejado estos
choques a lo largo de estas semanas
allana villacorta nos cuenta más sobre
el panorama colombiano en el siguiente
informe
[Música]
colombia está cerca de cumplir un mes de
manifestaciones antigubernamentales lo
que empezó como una protesta pacífica en
contra de la reforma tributaria ha
desencadenado enfrentamientos violentos
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y los
manifestantes el abuso policial es
reflejado en las cifras reportadas más
de 129 desapariciones y 27 casos de
violencia sexual situación que alarma a
la comunidad internacional hemos
recibido denuncias creíbles sobre 61
muertes ocurridas en colombia desde que
comenzaron las protestas hasta ahora
hemos confirmado que 24 de esas muertes
22 manifestantes o transeúntes y dos
policías tienen relación con las
manifestaciones sin embargo el gobierno
de iván duque no permitió la visita de
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos para verificar las denuncias
pero el paro nacional no da su brazo a
torcer nosotros estamos llamados a la
movilización
social y comunitaria del país como
pueblos originarios ya que con este
gobierno hemos tenido
las mayores violaciones de nuestros
derechos derecho de todos los
colombianos se ha manoseado la
constitución porque en la constitución
están garantizados los derechos para
todos entonces eso lo que estamos
manifestando en las calles sin violencia
las reuniones entre el comité nacional
de paro y el gobierno están estancadas
el gobierno ha condicionado la
negociación al desbloqueo de las vías
que traen consigo desabastecimiento de
alimentos y medicinas mientras que los
manifestantes exigen medidas contra la
brutalidad policía el conservador
guillermo lazo asumió la presidencia de
ecuador en su discurso de investidura
del nuevo mandatario destacó que
construirá un país desde el reencuentro
alejado del odio político y abierto al
mundo y de unidad de los diferentes
sectores de la sociedad ecuatoriana pero
lazos llega al poder con una minoría en
la asamblea nacional lo que ha llevado a
que tenga que realizar alianzas con los
diferentes partidos
esto genera incertidumbre sobre la
gobernabilidad que tendrá y también
tendrá que hacer frente a una compleja
situación económica y social para
analizar este tema saludamos a
cordero ellas politóloga y también es
docente del instituto de altos estudios
nacionales según esta conversación desde
la ciudad de quito la capital
ecuatoriana muy buenos días señora
cordero gracias por estar con nosotros y
desde su perspectiva y dada esta
división que presenta la asamblea en
ecuador el consenso que ya ha tratado de
construir lazos con algunas de las
formaciones políticas y también la
polarización que hay en ecuador que
tanto margen de maniobrabilidad de
gobernabilidad tendrá el nuevo
mandatario
buenos días sí justamente el margen de
maniobra estará dado por el apoyo que
consiga de las fuerzas a las que terminó
aliándose en primera instancia que son
pachakuti la izquierda democrática el
discurso de ayer dio buenas señales
porque guillermo lazo se ubicó más en el
centro es decir en una derecha moderada
o un centro político iu y psoe e iu
soluciones a por ejemplo el crecimiento
macroeconómico pero al mismo tiempo
justicia social la lucha por la igualdad
de género por ejemplo el tema
ambientalista el tema de la desnutrición
infantil y todas las de emergencias
sociales que son demandas de esos
sectores que hasta ahora él han apoyado
para la elección de las autoridades en
la asamblea la presidencia de la
asamblea sobre todo en ese orden de
ideas entonces qué prioridades tendría
que tener el presidente de lazo porque
las necesidades son muchas pero los
recursos son pocos y además debe tomar
decisiones rápidas y eso significa tener
que negociar en las
y las prioridades sin duda tienen que
ser cumplir con su plan de vacunación
que ha ofrecido en 90 días vacunar a 9
millones de personas o tratar de cumplir
de la mejor manera y luego afrontar el
tema del desempleo y el tema de la
desnutrición infantil que es un tema que
está preocupando y está digamos que se
ha agudizado de una manera importante y
las demandas las demandas de la sociedad
civil y de estos sectores que por
ejemplo atraviesan también el tema de la
sociedad la seguridad social perdón
y hacer una reforma que asegure la
seguridad social como un mecanismo de
solidaridad y de aseguramiento para los
jubilados y para los jóvenes que
empiezan a aportar desde ya
al sistema y como debe el presidente
lazo entonces balancear estas reformas
sobre todo en la materia económica que
es compleja en este país para que no
aparezcan demasiados radicales en
ecuador también hay un descontento
social por la economía del país por la
situación de la pandemia
incluso en el 2019 hubo marchas
ciudadanas que llevaron a que el
presidente de turno tuviera que revertir
algunas decisiones que había tomado
justamente un equilibrio entre lo
macroeconómico como el ha mencionado la
apertura la apertura comercial al mundo
la entrada a la alianza del pacífico
pero al mismo tiempo no descuidar el
gasto social es decir no descuidar
políticas sociales para enfrentar la
crisis actual que preocupan que atienden
las necesidades más urgentes de quienes
le dieron su voto en la segunda vuelta
sofía cordero en la ciudad de quito
gracias por este análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 gracias por estar
con nosotros vamos a cambiar de tema
hace un año el ciudadano afroamericano
george floyd murió a manos del ex
policía derek joven cuando éste lo
asfixió al ponerle su rodilla en el
cuello por espacio de 9 minutos su
fallecimiento desató una serie de
manifestaciones de indignación y de
protestas contra el racismo y contra la
violencia policial que trascendió
incluso las fronteras de eeuu en el
marco del primer aniversario de la
muerte de floyd el presidente de eeuu
joe biden
recibirá a los familiares de la víctima
hace un año el asesinato de george floyd
desató las mayores protestas anti
racistas y contra la brutalidad policial
en décadas alrededor del planeta la
víspera del aniversario de su muerte
cientos de personas salieron a
recordarlo
la policía ha causado tanto dolor para
tantas familias y un año después no
deberíamos estar aquí suplicando cambios
en la legislación esta debería ser la
última de nuestras preocupaciones
mientras enterramos a nuestros seres
queridos la sentencia contra el ex
policía derecho vincule pavle de
asesinato en segundo y tercer grado y de
homicidio en segundo grado fue celebrada
como histórica a raíz del dictamen el
presidente estadounidense condenó el
racismo sistémico que mancha el país
ahora baiden insiste en la necesidad de
aprobar el proyecto de ley y justicia
para georges floyd
la legislación incluye la prohibición de
técnicas de inmovilización como la de
ahogamiento con la que el expolicía
blanco derek joven mató al
afroestadounidense de 46 años y un
registro de agresiones policiales la
cámara de representantes de mayoría
demócrata aprobó la legislación a
principios de marzo pero ahora está en
punto muerto en el senado y no borrará
siglos de racismo sistémico y excesos
policiales y no volverá georg floyd y
brión a taylor digan su nombre
rihanna taylor barberi y de incontables
otras webs
pero supondrá un enorme paso adelante
para frenar la violencia el sufrimiento
y comenzar a construir un mejor eeuu de
américa
el nombre de georg floyd ha quedado
grabado en la historia ahora la lucha
del movimiento black lives matter es que
la cambie vamos hasta áfrica en mali el
presidente y el primer ministro de
transición de ese país pasaron la noche
bajo detención de los militares quienes
los arrestaron después de perder dos de
sus integrantes en una reestructuración
del ejecutivo de s
la maniobra es calificada por la
comunidad internacional como un intento
de golpe de estado por parte de los
militares para la jornada de hoy se
espera que llegue a bamako la capital
del país una misión de la comunidad
económica de eeuu de áfrica occidental
para buscar una salida a esta crisis
política en madrid
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias aquí en france 24 siga con
nuestra programación muy buenos días
[Música]